dans un monde lançait la tétanisation
bon dans un autre monde
notre galaxie est en état d' alerte
capitaine qwark les rangers galactiques
ont besoin d'une nouvelle recrue un
homme avec un rêve
en fait je suis en bac sont d'accord un
lombax avec un rêve c'est vous que nous
voulons aller si vous êtes trois jeux
alors servait à la hauteur tu n'es pas à
la hauteur suivant naîtra une magnifique
amitié bon ok pas forcément si
magnifique mais fracassante disons 7 sur
10 je m'appelle ratchet je crois qu'il
est appelé torte plonger dans le côté
obscur de l'univers dans seulement deux
jours les ranchs ans galactique seront
anéantis exxon est une autre twitter
mais un être maléfique
ils sont limite à tout faire
vraiment sans limites assez les plombs
quand péter va leur donner la chance une
attaque est imminente
il me faut prévenir les rangers ce jeu
préfet l'aappma de devenir des héros
nommant des légendes n'en attendait
encore mieux qui d'autre est partant
pour aller tout de suite leur mettre une
grosse patte et le 13 avril massacrer
les tous
lorsqu'une force galactique menace le
monde je pense dans ta équipez-vous bien
prouver votre courage voici le bouton à
ta planète
ratchet et clank
il surprenant que la rupture de ces
vérités relatives à notre inertie n'est
pas entraîner chez vous donne une envie
de noms ne vous inquiète pas petit ça
arrive même aux meilleurs
j'ai super mal au bide